There a few key challenges in implementing
this Andrew system, which is intended for
campus environment. User community consisting of students,
who can login to work stations anywhere
on campus and those workstation are connected
by insecure network links to central server.
And a simple server is a depository for all the files of the entire
user community. So the challenges include authenticating a user.
That is, when a user says I'm Kishore, the system has to
verify unambiguously, that the user indeed is Kishore.
A second challenge is authenticating the server. That is, if
I, as a user, log into a work station and I get
a message from the server, I have to
be assured that this message is actually coming
from the server. And not some Trojan horse
that is pretending to be the server. The third
challenge is preventing replay attacks. And what that
means, is that even though we using encryption
to secure the data that is going on
the wire, someone that is sniffing the wire Could
grab a packet and then resend that same packet, and that should
not fool either the sender or the receiver. That's what is meant by
replay attack, and the [UNKNOWN] challenge is of course ensuring that the user
community is shielded from one another. Either due to unintended
interference of user or another, or malicious interference.
Both of those situations have to be avoided.
So that is what I meant by isolating
users. So these are the design challenges for
the Andrew system. So in the Andrew file
system, they decided in order to make sure
that all of these challenges are met, they
have to use a secure rpc as the
basis for client server communication. And, in implementing the
secure rpc, they also decided to use private
key cryptosystem, and I mentioned. That the public key
crypto system does not have the key distribution
problem, but on the other hand, for a closed
community like a campus environment, the key distribution
problem is not as big a challenge, so therefore,
the design of the Andrew file system decided to
use private key crypto system. And as I mentioned
earlier in the private key crypto key system
in order to identify what key to use
to decrypt a message that is coming in,
the identity of the sender has to be known.
So this has to be sent in clear text. If you take a traditional operating system
like Unix you have username and password which
is the way you authenticate yourself for the system.
But, in a campus environment if you're going
to use, Secure RPC as a mechanism for
communication between the client and the server. There
can be lots of communication that is happening between
individual clients and the servers. And if you're
going to use, use a name and password all
the time for such communication. Such overuse will
result in a security hold. One of the things
that I mentioned, as a principle proposed by Jerome Salser is you publish the
design but protect the keys, but you publish the design but protect the keys.
And what is meant by protecting the keys is making it competitionally hard to
break the key but over exposing the key. Allows someone to take a long
time to crack the key, and therefore
overusing username and password as the basis
for all communications, in a circular RPC,
will pose a security hole. So the dilemma
that the Andrew Fine system designers had to face, was what to
use as the identity. That needs to be sent in cleartext, and
what to use as the private key so that we don't always
use any pair of identity and private keys for a long time.